Congress's shutdown people have you
heard about that that's right with their
whopping ten percent approval rating
which it's like as high as it's been in
years they decided to walk out this is
the House GOP decided to shut down the
government mostly the Tea Party faction
because they're not happy with Obamacare
but don't take my word for it let's
let's find out a little information
about the shutdown okay so a real simple
explanation of the shutdown and what it
means basically every year the
government has to pass a budget by a
certain deadline to continue existing
this deadline was midnight on Monday
this year some Republicans basically the
Tea Party wing in the House refused to
pass a budget unless we get rid of or
delay Obamacare which obviously Obama
has backed in the Supreme Court has said
is legal Obama and the Democrats say
they won't be held hostage by
Republicans trying to get what they want
since everyone including Congress and
the Supreme Court already upheld
Obamacare that's what I just said and
the government will come back when they
pass a budget okay so we are in day two
of this the World War Two memorial was
blocked off the there's this thing that
the NIH where kids with cancer aren't
getting trials I mean this is just
absolutely absurd as we tape this right
the second it just broke that Obama is
gonna meet with Boehner and Harry Reid
today so maybe something will happen but
President Obama had this to say at the
White House yesterday Republicans in the
House of Representatives refused to fund
the government unless we defunded or
dismantled the Affordable Care Act
they've shut down the government over an
ideological crusade to deny affordable
health insurance to millions of
Americans in other words they demanded
ransom just for doing their job okay so
there you have it President Obama is
being very clear this is a law that was
already passed and now they're trying to
stop the government because they don't
like the law which everybody knew is
that is a hundred percent blame here on
this Tea Party faction of the GOP I'm
gonna put it at they're give a get the
two percent
senator Ted Cruz gets another 98
this I mean this is a really laser
pointer this is where it originated I
mean we of course the the different
resolution at least they're different
budget came up through the house ted
cruz's the senator you wonder why i'm
connecting the two he basically and this
has been said today to he basically told
them i need you guys to send up this
stupid bill that that defunds Obamacare
or at least delays it for another year
and then included with I have a great
idea with our budget so that we can
either be forced to go along what we
need to do now he was getting pushback
from that before finally happened but we
had people like represent of Peter King
and he came on said this guy is crazy
but you know we're gonna give what he
wants and watch him just floundering and
watch him fall apart in front of all of
us Peter King a guy who I'm pretty sure
you wouldn't agree with on 90% of the
stuff but you're giving him some credit
ya know was think now I also said a few
weeks ago he's he's already mentioned a
little bit he wants to run for president
it's insane to me but and then so the if
you read you know I guess the writing on
the wall sort of senator Cruz so I think
he's already going after Cruz to be like
this guy is gonna have way more support
than I will have more money so they make
sure I get ahead of this and disparage
him right now I think that's his
motivation yeah which is fine is they're
gonna fight later but he actually comes
on the right side of this because there
is no real end game hey Rita this is
dead when he gets to the Senate Obama
said come on you think I'm gonna sign
this so it's it's never gonna work that
way so it was all just a stunt really to
get more attention on senator Cruz now
the house would long love it and parsing
for this reason and I think others went
along there because they kind of have to
cuz they're Republicans and they'll have
any any real thoughts for themselves so
now the support is now building behind
what Cruz started it looks like the
entire party has started and it's
damaging them all right okay so Jr's
given us a nuts-and-bolts here but what
do you think about the broader point of
everyone having to stick with party all
the time and being held hostage by this
little group of people and all that I'll
use some media reference analogies I
like in this scenario to Arlen Rickman
robbing the Nakatomi building claiming
that this is very political when they
were just robbing they just wanted money
they were just robbing the building and
pretending it was political and that's
from his perspective that's what he's
doing now
let's go over to what is Obama doing I
think this is Obama's Breaking Bad
closing episode where he doesn't mind
how much damage this does his image as
long as he knows he completely took the
other side out in the process
I like these references there's a Walter
on them you know yeah that was our first
die-hard reference ever on the show I
like oh there you go very nice they are
playing a fake indignation thing where
clearly if you're examine their behavior
them actually care about any of the
things that's the whole point of being
fake royalty or whatever you think
royalties new name is for the 21st
century so you can live on this land and
be it you know oligarchy whatever you
want to call it I think oh my god no
point of oligarchy is I get to tell you
not to do something and then what close
my door I get to do it exactly so it's
the whole point of being me yeah so
speaking of the fake indignation because
that's what this now seems to be about
now that we were you know into day two
of this this idea of the World War Two
memorial being closed and again the
veterans can't get in there and you know
that the Republicans are now saying well
will not even get paid because
everyone's just playing these little
games how do we get this thing how do we
get the discussion out of the
nonsensical games because if you watch
cable news it's just endless bickering
back and forth and and it mean forward
to get back to actual nuts and bolts
yeah people actually see and hear that
yeah as I was trying to rush through all
of it there was still five more things I
was thinking I was like this is
beginning to get boring I should stop
yeah that was there was just the
internal voice in my head was going I
should stop with this spattering of
everything that's going on because no
one wants to hear that and so that's
gonna be the general in the conventional
wisdom the assignment is regardless of
what you're faced with you try and get
it out anyway regardless of how the
initial reaction to us some something
that is like waking up in your tub of
goo in the matrix of the wires shooting
at your head and you realize what your
real existence is that's kind of
shocking a lot of people don't want to
admit that right off the bat because
what does it make you do it makes you
you're so decades-long wrong you've been
wrong for decades who wants to own that
who wants to say I've been born wrong it
was really bad well that's very
convenient way to lock that out even
though there may be a whisper trying to
remind you of it when you're shaving in
the morning you know and there's ways to
go into denial but I think that other
voice when enough data is faced the
other way that voice inside gets louder
and louder you can't ignore me anymore
man it's on every channel you flip to
yeah
now you got a look hey guys the Reuben
report is brought to you by Cooper comm
they've got 75% off dog and cat choose
toys accessories home goods and more use
code RR for 20% off your next purchase
the link is right down there